Earlier this week the Council held its monthly meeting for November.
It started with a presentation from Sam Huo, who was representing the ownership of Pegasus Golf Club.
He updated the Council about Pegasus hosting
the NZPGA Championship tournament for the
next three years, and talked about future
plans to construct accommodation and conference
facilities at the golf course.
The Council also formally adopted the Kaiapoi
Town Centre Plan: 2028 and Beyond.
It promotes a vision of a vibrant Town Centre
that embraces the river, attracts visitors
and new businesses and creates enjoyable public
spaces.
For the first time, it also includes Masterplans
for the Mixed-Use Business Areas that were
set aside following the Canterbury earthquakes.
Because of the large amount of land available
for development, it’s considered a long-term
plan and could take the next 20 to 30 years to be fully realised.
The Council also approved a submission on
behalf of the Waimakariri District to the
Draft Regional Public Transport Plan.
This document plans for the region’s public
transport needs for the next 10 years and
beyond.
Our council strongly advocated for higher
frequency services between Christchurch and
our main towns.
We also asked that the committee be more ambitious
in trialling new transport technologies and
developing demand responsive services for
our smaller or more remote population centres.
The final monthly Council Meeting for the
year, will be held on Tuesday 4 December.